we're probably going to all be destroyed
by an asteroid you probably knew that
already they have been entering our
atmosphere for a long long time you may
even remember this one from Russia last
year alright that's just one example and
this has been happening all over the
place Russian talk radio sounds really
terrible by the way but we're just a
matter of time away from this
alright so that's from the movie deep
impact remember that came out like the
same week that Armageddon came out they
had two asteroid movies that's the much
better one in my humble opinion but
don't worry about asteroids people
because the UN is on it because they're
so good at everything aren't they the
special political and decolonization
committee is welcoming the idea of
setting up a series of groups to act as
a warning system they're going to deal
with issues related to decolonization
human rights peacekeeping outer space
atomic radiation and more the UN
literally can't do anything on earth but
apparently we're gonna be able to do
things off planet and they also have an
office for outer space affairs and let's
let's look at the International
mechanism which they've set up to deal
with asteroids the International
asteroid warning network comprises of a
wide spectrum of organizations for
discovering monitoring and
characterizing potential hazardous
near-earth objects it will recommend
criteria for notification of an
emergency impact threat and to study and
plans response activities take it away
to here's the space mission planning
advisory group statement the main
objective of this group to be
established would be to lay out the
framework timeline and options for
initiating and executing space mission
response activities moving report no
Reuben repairing exotica I had to read
it alright sorry you look the UN does
not do much of anything some good stuff
with feeding people but there's so much
so they just do it how creepy no no I'm
saying that's good they do some good
stuff but so much of what they do is
just bureaucratic nonsense we still have
people being slaughtered in Syria and
nothing's really changing so is there
any chance that this group of people in
suits and ties and bureaucrats and
technocrats can sit down and figure out
a problem as big as when an asteroid is
going to destroy Earth well I think the
truth the truth is that there are space
agencies across the world and those
space agencies are not unified and the
hope would be that if there were an
impending threat that one of the Space
Agency's I don't think that the UN that
this organization is probably going to
be the go-to for monitoring of
near-earth impacts right they're not
going to be monitoring asteroids or
meteors
very closely I know that there was some
talk about raising enough money to put
out a telescope specifically for that
but I think that there are organizations
that are better equipped to do that so
long as we don't continue to defund them
right the problem is those organization
own asset is an American organization
you have the Russian space agency we've
shown that partnerships work very well
we no longer have shuttles so we now
ride the Soyuz capsule to get up to the
International Space Station right isn't
that so people don't really realize this
the Russians actually now have to take
us right to the International Space
Station we used to go we don't do that
yeah until until kind of a private space
company perhaps SpaceX or virgin
galactic can put together a rocket
that's not just delivering payload but
can actually deliver humans we're
relying on the Russians now in order to
get up to the ISS so I think the issue
here is that we are a globe we have a
global society if an asteroid is going
to impact earth ultimately and that is a
legitimate possibility we have to have a
plan in place and relying on in any one
individual nation to play big brother
may not be the best way to do it so
whether it's the UN or another global
organization don't get me wrong we have
we don't have a good track record of
playing nice with other countries but I
think that it is important for us to be
able to maybe it sounds like hippie
dippie [ __ ] but you be able to band
together and work together to prevent
catastrophe right and that's my point
the UN doesn't really work well together
to prevent things that are happening on
earth so is there any chance we could
come together and well build some sort
of supervised right question those the
right question is there not a better
option there's a pic a question Guinea
and there's a couple of subtextual
things that are at work here first of
all recently the Japanese Space
Administration and I don't remember what
they're called we did some math on a
meteor that the u.s. had said was not
going to impact earth in 2032 and said I
we think it's a lot more likely than you
do and that started to create the the
sense that there is a need for greater
communication between international
space agencies but moreover this I think
we as a species have been
widely and largely distracted by
fantasies of Apocalypse since the
beginning of organized government
governance the sense that things are
going to end soon keeps people
distracted from solving large societal
problems and these societal problems are
caused by economic influences far more
than by any force of nature and you know
economic influences are purely abstract
and money doesn't really exist it's just
a sort of an agreed-upon abstraction of
value I just watch that guy's the movie
so I'm on board that I'm glad to hear
that someone watch that done so and it
sounds like I had something to do with
it yeah did you get your training
endorsement yeah uh so we're dealing
with the the apocalyptic fantasy of
modern America isn't that 57 horsemen
five horsemen free horsemen however many
horse that's not going to happen and the
the zombie guy isn't going to have a
scientific apocalypse fantasy and that
all sort of frees us of responsibility
for things like you know we're making
the Pacific Ocean radioactive I don't
worry about it a meteorite is going to
come in 2032 you know we've got people
starving all over the wealthiest nation
in history don't worry about it we're
all going to die in a couple of years we
can't really solve all those problems in
that much time and my feeling is what we
should do and again it may sound hippie
dippie is said about joining together to
solve human problems where we can as we
can for the good of humanity and then if
there is a sudden horrific death to
everything that we know that can just
come as a happy surprise but right then
we did that we did the best we could
yeah I think those are some really
really good points i think the one thing
that i would add to that is that it
doesn't have to be an either/or scenario
yes but within a certain organization
perhaps it does maybe the UN obviously
doesn't have the organizational skills
or the manpower to even address some of
the humanitarian crises that
they were first banded together to be
able to address so maybe this is better
left not in the hands of the UN but of
some sort of coalition of the existing
space agencies right the UN can serve
perhaps as a bridging mechanism between
you don't even need to there may be some
sort of treaty that establish amongst
the different space agencies we already
see that fundamentally the scientists
who work there are interested in you
know preventing catastrophe and in in
bettering the lives of everybody on the
globe through space exploration they all
have a common goal there which is to
learn as much about the cosmos as we can
in order to help us more here on earth
and you already see so many kind of
international coalition's that are
forming to try and get people to Mars to
try and get people back to the moon try
and get people as we were just saying to
the ISS why couldn't there be some sort
of asteroid watch coalition that was a
that was presented between all of those
different organisms yeah so is part of
the problem here also that we go as sort
of as you're saying we go from human
crisis team in crisis remember when
everyone thought y2k was gonna end the
world right then two years ago or was it
last year what year was I guess 2012 we
thought the Mayan thing was gonna rule
so we kill me nobody legitimately
thought somehow what a guy nobody who
like read a book really don't know what
I thought one person did but really when
these types of things come up and then
nothing happens and everyone always
thinks every other year you know the
Antichrist is coming tackle think that
when we actually have something that
legitimately could do it like an
asteroid we can't really band together
because we've had these sort of cry
Wolfe more so I think even with things
like asteroids we are crying wolf I mean
you see the same thing you know there's
a difference between legitimate threats
and illegitimate threats you know is a
Satan gonna come to earth no want to be
riding an asteroid isn't that what they
would say is there gonna be a zombie
apocalypse no but when people get scared
about swine flu or bird flu it's it's
it's more approaching a legitimate fear
of course though there's so much fear
mongering in the media that even swine
flu and bird flu weren't legitimate
fears for some sort of like cataclysmic
event right and so I think what it's
really about is understanding the data
understanding scale and and being able
to to know the difference between a
legitimate risk
cheeks and a risk that has been blown
out of proportion by that's exactly
right bring us home again human love
drama we live for drama we remember the
exciting moments and we seek out the
exciting moments and at this point our
we have the most powerful technology for
information and education that has ever
been available to us and instead all we
are using it for is titillation of the
drama impulse so you know news stations
the purported mainstream news and I'm
using the term so loosely are in the
business of selling xanax because that's
their sponsor and the human mind is
hardwired so that if you're in the
forest foraging for food and there's a
fuzzy rabbit you might be able to eat
you look at the rabbit because it's
moving but then if there's a bear that
might kill you your focus is on the bear
it's got to be on the bear until the
bear is gone and all the news does now
is say look at the bear buy xanax look
at the bear buy xanax that's all it does
hey guys the Reuben reports brought to
you by Cooper calm they have up to
seventy-five percent off pet treats
choose toys and more and if you use code
are are you get another twenty percent
that's a lot of percentage right there I
can't do that kind of math the link is
right down below Cooper calm code RR